habrá conexión energética entre la
Península ibérica y Francia pero no será
a través de los pirineos como pretendían
inicialmente España y Portugal esta se
dará a través de una tubería submarina
que una de las ciudades costeras de
Barcelona en España y Marsella en
Francia una solución alcanzada en
Bruselas que parece agradar a los tres
países involucrados y que en tierra de
una vez por todas el midcat proyecto al
que Emmanuel macron se oponía
rotundamente pese a la presión ejercida
incluso por el canciller Alemán o
lapsols el corredor de energía verde bar
Marc servirá en un futuro para el
transporte de hidrógeno verde pero a
corto plazo funcionará como gasoducto
que cubra las necesidades energéticas
del mercado europeo ha afectado por la
escasez de gas proveniente de Rusia el
presidente del gobierno de España Pedro
Sánchez recordó que su país es uno de
los integrantes de la Unión Europea con
el mayor número de plantas de
gasificadoras de gas licuado y como tal
puede ser material energética y dar
respuesta a la demanda del resto de
países del bloque los detalles sobre los
plazos de la obra sus costes y el
reparto de estos se Irán definiendo en
esta semanas y en una reunión de Manuel
macron Antonio Costa y Pedro Sánchez el
9 de diciembre en la ciudad española de
alicante durante la Cumbre euromed que
reúne a los nueve países mediterráneos
de la Unión Europea